I wrote it, I sent it, I'm ****d
- So I had a one night
stand with this guy
and it was so good that I was
like, "I'm a repeat customer."
So I was trying to make
it a two night stand.
So I was texting him,
getting all sexy.
I was sexting him;
saying things like,
"Come over, I'll S your
D, I'll eat your butt,
"I'll lick your toes,
I'll be a freak for you,"
even though I don't
like any of that stuff.
Except of the S-ing of
the D; I love (beep).
And then I was kind of drunk.
(siren)
So I ended up passing out.
Before I had fallen asleep
I had lit a candle
and like passed out.
And I had taken off my wig.
And when I woke up I was
cradling my wig like a baby
and the candle
was still burning.
I mean this is so funny,
so I was texting my friend.
Be like, "Girl, you'll never
guess what happened last night.
"I was trying to get
some. Lit a candle,
"took off my wig
and passed out."
So then I hit send and realized
I sent it to him and
I was like, "Oh no!"
And he responded with,
"I don't think you meant
to send that to me."
I was like, "Ooh think fast.
"I got it.
"I did mean to send it to you.
"Do you wanna come over?
"I'll put my wig on.
"I'll suck your D right now."
And he said, "No."
(drip)
Protip!
If you're holding your
wig, no one's holding you.